hi there here i am in
heraklion iraqi
in crete
uh it's day two
it has been wonderful
uh rarely have have i had such a
positive reaction from people
when i speak their language so the
six months or so that i've put into
learning greek
has been well worth it
very friendly very proud of their island
yesterday we visited the museum where a
lot of the
artifacts from the minoan
civilization are kept that was
fascinating then today we went to
knossos
went there by
taxi our taxi driver just explaining
everything about the island how proud he
is and everything else and then we took
a guide at the knossos palace because
otherwise you're just looking at a lot
of rocks
and stones and it was fascinating and
the idea of there was a civilization
there 4 000 years ago they were here on
this island which is one of the larger
islands in the mediterranean
they were peaceful
they traded with mainland greece and
particularly with
anatolia with uh
you know call it uh asia minor and a lot
of even
people came from there a lot of their
culture came from there there was a lot
of trade with
that mesopotamia also with egypt and so
they were part of this sort of network
in the eastern mediterranean they
developed their own very advanced
culture
because they were a wealthy trading
country because they
had these influences because it was
peaceful because they had wise rulers uh
whatever and to see their for example
the uh
the plumbing collet system where they
collected rain water they
had a flushed toilet they had a way to
deal with waste wastewater
it was really quite spectacular to see
and also the the decorative quality of
of the material that we saw at the
museum and also today at the palace
and of course unlike my stay in
israel having invested six months in
learning greek i am actually able to
communicate
even though i'm able to listen to and
understand
a large part of podcasts about the
building of the acropolis that's over
and so on when confronted with real-life
people speaking to you very quickly then
you're able to grab less of it and of
course i'm able to use
a much smaller percentage of what i am
able to understand
and
here i'm traveling with a couple from
vancouver who are chinese so i spent
most of my time speaking chinese not
speaking greek
so that the the
degree to which i can activate my greek
here is not quite what i
was able to enjoy in la viv ukraine
where i had
a ukrainian tutor three hours in the
morning three hours in the afternoon for
six days
and was speaking a lot of ukrainian here
i'm not speaking so much greek but i'm
enjoying the company of our friends i am
speaking some greek
but it reminds me that in order to like
for example in israel
you know i put a little bit of effort
into it
but uh
the the idea that you can suddenly start
saying things
is uh there's some people enjoying my
selfie video here
um
again and that was my experience too in
vietnam that uh despite trying to learn
a few phrases it's very difficult to
just use phrases like that if you have a
better base in the language such as i
have in in greek then you can very
quickly catch catch up with sort of the
basic greeting and polite conversation
type of stuff if i were
here if i had an opportunity to speak
a few hours a day i think my the rest of
my greek would activate but if i find
that opportunity i might uh maybe do a
conversation with someone in greek later
on anyway there you have it that's my
video for today bye for now oh and
behind me is the venetian fort because
crete
uh was under the venetians for a few
hundred years before being conquered by
the ottoman empire
bye for now
[Music]
you